NEW ENGLAND JOURNAL OF MEDICINE"
SAYS THE U.S. HAS FAILED THE
LEADERSHIP TEST CREATED BY THE
VIRUS.
OVERSEAS, A MEDIA GROUP AS A
STAGING A RALLY NEAR THE
WHITE HOUSE URGING SUPPORT FOR
THE COUNTRY IN ITS FIGHT OVER
AZERBAIJAN OVER DISPUTED
TERRITORY.
THE U.S., FRANCE, AND RUSSIA ARE
STEPPING UP EFFORTS TO GET A
CEASE-FIRE THERE.
WE HAVE AN EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW
WITH ARMENIA’S PRESIDENT WAS
POINTING THE FINGER AT ANOTHER
REGIONAL PLAYER.
>> IT’S A LONG, SIMMERING, AND
COMPLEX CONFLICT IN A REMOTE
CORNER OF THE FORMER
SOVIET UNION BUT SUDDENLY THE
WORLD HAS STOOD UP TO LISTEN
LIKE NEVER BEFORE -- IT MAY NO
LONGER JUST BE ARMENIANS AND
AZERBAIJANI FIGHTING OVER A
TERRITORY THE SIZE OF
DELAWARE -- ARMENIA’S
PRESIDENT -- TURKEY’S JUMPING IN
AND UPPING THE STAKES.
>> IT’S BECOME A BIG REASON REGI
CONFLICT.
ISLAMIC TERRORISTS INTO
AZERBAIJAN.
>> EVEN SYRIA HAS CLAIMED THAT
SOME OF ITS CITIZENS HAVE HEADED
INTO THE FRAY, THE SENIOR
FOREIGN POLICY ADVISOR TO
AZERBAIJAN DENIES THE
ALLEGATIONS.
RUSSIA AND IRAN HAVE VOICED
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS WAR ZONE AND
ARE CAREFULLY WEIGHING OPTIONS,
THEY ARE ALL NEIGHBORS AND
AZERBAIJAN INSIST TURKEY IS A
GOOD NEIGHBOR
IT SITS WITHIN THE NATIONAL
BOUNDARIES OF AZERBAIJAN BUT
IT’S POPULATED BY ARMENIANS AND
RUNS AS ITS OWN COUNTRY.
WITH EACH SIDE CARRYING OUT
ETHNIC CLEANSING FROM ITS
ANCIENT LAND WITH CULTURAL
SIGNIFICANCE ON THE EDGE OF AN
ENERGY RICH REGION WHICH IS
ANOTHER REASON THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF ARMENIA INSIST
TURKEY WANTS INROADS.
>> SOMEHOW, EUROPE WILL BECOME A
HOSTAGE OF TURKEY, CLOSING AND
OPENING PIPELINES.
>> THE TURKISH PRESIDENT VOICED
FULL THROATED SUPPORT OF
AZERBAIJAN ACCUSING THE
ARMENIANS OF HAVING A SPOILED
AND UNCOMPROMISING ATTITUDE,
THIS AS THE U.S., FRANCE, AND
RUSSIA HELD TALKS IN GENEVA TO
TRY TO DE-ESCALATE THE SITUATION